all right with the recent popularity of
blade and your recent disappointment
with Steel
I really thought Shaquille O'Neal is
going to be the next Mark Wahlberg it
just makes sense to discuss who will get
what going forward yeah that dark
softwood blade we're pretty well we're
gonna try something that new our next
seven movies are gonna be cashing in on
the dark stuff destined to all be hits
oh we got is like hearted crap coming up
well that's why you have the caped
crusader
after Batman and Robin nobody's gonna
want to see another Batman movie in here
hey we're switching it up - we've got a
colorful and corny Spider Man movie
coming out from the director of evil
dead yeah it's probably not gonna break
any records but it should be a huge hit
with the kids fine I guess we'll do
another Batman movie even though there's
no money in it Christ hears from now
everyone's gonna associate Marvel with
dark and gritty and DC with bright and
playful right well then there should be
no problem signing this television
contract
wait this is affecting our shows - oh
yes see all of your TV series will be
upbeat and positive while all of ours
are going to be depressing and harsh
it'll make you want to kill yourself but
what have we end up completely
misunderstanding our audiences and we
end up doing the exact opposite it's
okay
our animation departments will fill in
the blanks we'll keep ours goofy and
harmless while you keep yours complex
and intriguing with some exceptions but
what if somehow DC's material for
children and subduing more don't work
than our material for adults our two
version of The Killing Joke with a
hard-r rating that was bizarrely
specific yeah so anything else one more
thing
are you sure you don't want any of your
shows to be tied to this new Netflix
format that's getting a lot of buzz yeah
like anything's gonna kill cable no you
guys can handle that besides we don't
want to be known as those guys to always
copy marvel that is a very valid point
so anything else yeah what are our plans
in terms of comics who gives a shit yeah
all done
hello I'm a Nostalgia Critic I remember
it so you don't have to comic book
movies have had a lot of ups and downs
over the years sometimes they are on top
of the world and sometimes they were
daredevil but when comic book films were
seen at their most unpopular one little
kick-ass movie came along and said hey
not only am I gonna be awesome but
people are gonna completely overlook me
when they say Deadpool was the first
r-rated comic book flick
how do you sleep at night internet how
do you sleep at night I'm of course
talking about the late 90s head blade
people talk about influence in recent
comic book films they easily go to the
Dark Knight or Avengers but many forget
this did play a big part in not only
getting popularity back to the genre but
also creating a ton of tropes still used
in comic book movies today written by
David s Goyer and directed by Stephen
Norrington to people you thought we're
gonna be comic book gods managed to turn
out a movie pretty cool and badass so
being about as 90s as a commercial where
kids rule does the classic coolness
overrule the dated silliness well let's
see if this vampire spectacle sucks in a
good way or a bad way
this is blade we open up with blades
birth seeing his mother slowly bleed to
death always a pleasant start the
credits roll as you can tell our a this
movie is a bad case of the 90 simply by
a sped up footage it was a simpler time
when we were so blown away by the
fast-forward button we see a woman
driving her day to apparently a hot
nightclub so what are we going to
surprise me I like surprises
yeah I'm just here to die or be saved
the character tool all the way enter a
club playing music that sounds like your
Atari is trying to throw rave when we
come across an effect even better than
speeding up the footage speeding up the
footage with a white flash handle this
you're blowing us away with what we hit
our computers for doing today but our
midnight snack is about to get a
surprise when he finds he stumbled into
a literal bloodbath I guess this is
supposed to be scary but nowadays you
probably just see this at any goth club
dude the blood is supposed to rain at
4:00 right now you're supposed to be
dangling the rubber games he fights all
of them have vampire fangs again usual
non scary occurrence of a goth club when
he comes across his knight in shining
leather blade played by Wesley Snipes
the vampires try their hardest to wave
their fingers at him but it doesn't work
as he partakes in some pretty kick-ass
fight scenes here
damn I possessed
what about can play the accordion to God
that usually wins over swinging hooks
even though the rotting remains are
about as real as the rotting remains
from a pumpkin bomb these fight
sequences are filled with the most
awesome of implausibility very unlikely
there I give you footage for like 50
trailers you know for a character this
badass that was a pretty dorky move you
now join the ranks that Kevin McAllister
data and that weird baby meme have made
timelessly awkward I'm just gonna zoom
you haven't seen the past twenty years
of white media time chuckling my second
go to I try and fire system on fire
while also saving the story pond as our
extra crispy vampire is sent to the
hospital here dr. Karen Jenson played by
the butcher right he's looking him over
with another doctor she used to date
ever have second thoughts about us
sometimes but then I remember how much
of an asshole you are trying really is
over Wow I carry the backstory seemed
really necessary well I still think we
can work no really there must be a
reason for that romantic interest it
seemed completely pointless came back to
finish you off
yeah this brings up a continuing
question about the film blade several
times is given opportunities to kill off
this character Quinn but he doesn't
result in tons of people either getting
killed or maimed like over and over and
over why does he have such a hard time
killing this guy off dear diary I almost
kill Quinn on this time but when I
looked into his dreamy eyes I knew I was
a Quinn girl forever
late is about to let the doctor died
when his damn Oedipus complex kicks in
reminding him of his dying mother and he
takes her to his hideout there we come
across world renowned plan of the ape
star Kris Kristofferson playing Whistler
who tries to heal her bite marks with
garlic holder Thanks that'll help a lot
I'll call you when an earthworm knees
restraining we're introduced to our
shadowy room of evil businesses because
Marvel will always love this cliche and
they bring in their evil as vampire who
can never get assured that Fitz Deacon
Frost play by Stephen Dorff this guy's a
lot of fun just imagine all of Edward
Norton's Mia faces Hanna's son and you
only listened to prodigy maybe it's time
we forgot about discretion we should be
ruling the humans or maybe I'm just the
first to say out loud thinking I propose
a movement where we dress like we don't
care how we look when really it's the
most important thing to us I call it the
hipster effect do we have any as a
business to discuss
Donna you may wake up one day and find
yourself extinct really we're just gonna
let him get away with that you know for
a guy who does things we don't like
Richard you let him do things that we
don't like the detector wakes up and
seems to be doing better as she sees
what blade has to go through in order to
survive
he just read the script to blade Trinity
I'd be holding his hand to Whistler
tells Karen exactly what they're
fighting against we gotta understand
they're everywhere
vampires the humblest Nocturna
that means vampires but seems frost is
doing research into the vampire archives
pissing off the council even more we're
in a library you don't need to shout
what do you like the frost tell me or
next time I'll actually hit you what are
you gonna do I don't need this I'm only
here because Chris Pine hasn't been
invented yet
boom well you wouldn't be the first so
after trying to figure out if a friggin
newspaper building blow up in town
seriously karen is told not to trust
anybody when she's suddenly approached
by a cop in her apartment police officer
I didn't mean to scare you the front
door was open what are you doing in here
I'm just here on a routine check I heard
you were black so you're under arrest
for something you're dead too Oh who'd
said I was a vampire
nobody rice I think plates whole goal in
this movie is to leave at bad times and
then come back just before things get
worse
okay I'm leaving I really leaving this
time does nobody care that a guy with a
sword is slamming a cop's head into a
car I mean never forget nwe but I think
someone would at least raise an um he
escapes though causing blade and Karen
to follow him through fast forward lane
if you want to do point with speedy
footage that's fine but at least haven't
talked the way they're supposed to talk
crosses are running water don't do dick
so forgive what you've seen in the
movies you use a snake so for some
weight yeah forget all that stuff you've
seen in the movies but concentrate on
this stuff like in the movies so when
the vampires sit around partying
watching Mortal Kombat yeah you vampires
are gonna find a lot of blood in that
movie the cop tells frost of his run-in
with blaze don't worry about it don't
snow problems still get the drug um am i
fired or is this a promotion as a guy
who wants to be a vampire I genuinely
don't know
in case you forgot that bat means that
they're vampires
symbolism blade and caring come across
the person who keeps track of all the
archives and okay even for a movie about
a guy who chases vampires that's pretty
silly
we'd be soil won't Oh looky good thing
he's not a woman or else that would
suddenly be indecent they get captured
by Quinn and his gang but it looks like
blade has back up catch you fuckers at a
bad time
as long as you don't have a copy of a
star is born then no they escape into a
subway that just happens to be connected
to the vampire archives odd design work
as they wait for the longest train ever
to pass and then end up literally
catching a ride on it
okay so Whistler reveals why blaze seems
to have all the vampires strengths and
few of their weaknesses blades mother
was attacked by a vampire while she was
pregnant she died but he lived he can
withstand garlic silver even sunlight he
also obtained an aversion to taxes as
well I like to point out I waited this
long to make a tax joke I think I did
pretty well
Karen consoles blade during his
all-important wall watching while Frost
and his goons apparently kidnapped the
leader of the vampires to kill him
but you probably all fry up but it's
okay because the other vampires have
sunblock in helmets was Marceline's Sun
Hat not available
Karen uses her doctor know how to figure
out how to make vampires heads explode
science when Whistler makes a discovery
about her you don't look so good
no I mean the studio won't let you look
bad so this is what we count is not good
I guess we didn't catch it so it looks
like she's still gonna turn into a
vampire in a day or two but that doesn't
get in the way of a meeting between
blade and the now helmetless frost so
wait a minute if you happen if some
black the day doesn't bother you cuz if
so being a vampire is literally a day at
the beach easy wouldn't want our little
friend here to wind up on the back of a
milk carton ever oh please he is saving
people is more of a secondary thing and
tries to shoot frost causing him to toss
the child dead oh I mean no scratch on
her whatsoever
she must been wearing a lot of sunblock
too
yeah what the hell do you think this guy
is talking about I mean I know we just
saw a man flying to the street save a
kid that we're all just gonna ignore it
well let me tell you about this cop who
got his head smashed into a car that I
ignored the city we're just kind of
there
you
it's hard being an artist when you have
headaches always popping up it affects
your work so no one takes you seriously
that's just a sugar-coated topic that
you can control try giving us Goya David
s Goyer seems effective at first like a
miracle you've always been looking for
but then on closer inspection you
realize it might not be as effective as
he thought your denial will tell you
it's doing a good job but after a while
you can't ignore the pain it's causing
it's not as bad as it was before but
it's still really bad people will like
your work at first because they see you
have cooler attached to it but then
they'll wake up and realize that most of
it was dumb luck surviving on the talent
of others everybody says the techniques
were great but the product was overall
shit you've not only realised it didn't
less than you thought but it's actually
slowing you down
compared to other successful medicines
at first I thought it worked great but
now I see it's just a bigger placebo
than Dumbo's magic fester
experts agree it's not the worst thing
out there it did some good things I
think though maybe that was other people
and come on just just come on David s
Goyer sooner or later you'll feel the
pain and don't forget to try nighttime
David s Goyer oh yes it will ruin the
Sandman
so Karen discovers a cure for turning
into a vampire off-screen yeah they're
surprisingly kind of lay back about it
the frost also discovers blades hideout
off-screen you know it's good to show
and don't tell believe don't do neither
you have neither and tries to capture
them stop aiming at the rails and maybe
you'll hit something believe comes home
to see what happened as he gives one
hell of an emotional breathtaking
Oscar caliber reaction to his fatherly
mentor being destroyed if only more
blood curling moments in cinema had
reactions like that I
whoof that sucks
Whistler still has a few breasts left in
him as he tell blade where they took
Karen Frost astride trigger oh yeah
that'll help them big time I can see why
you brought a doctor into your home now
walk away I'm just gonna last long
enough to be brought back into sequel
just to die again and another sequel
it's a well planned now future that lies
ahead for me yeah so played once again
breaks in the frost headquarters he
tears some vampires heads and to Bob the
Tomato but about the ketchup but inside
this giant macintosh cigarette case lies
a big secret
Eric yep blades mom is still alive and
it turns out she's a vampire now and on
the side of frost you think someone
would have used that bombshell a little
earlier man this blade guy is ruining my
plans and destroying my operation honey
what are you doing oh not now mother of
my enemy who he doesn't know is still
alive and on my side I had to figure out
a way to get rid of blade wait a minute
I love oreos
but there's an even bigger to waste all
that's spent a whole life looking for
the vampire bitch your mother
Here I am well it's a small convoluted
world after all after capturing him
Charon reveals a secret about the Cure
she's created if it works you lose your
strength and your ability to regenerate
you'll be completely human huh
so the Cure is totally friggin useless
don't get me wrong I know she uses it on
herself but from a story perspective
what happens she gets bitten they say
they didn't get to it in time so she
makes a cure if you just cut out them
not getting to it in time which adds
nothing to the plot at all the cure is
entirely not needed but it's okay
because if you love pointless drawn-out
moments you're gonna love what's coming
up next
see here's the setup frost needs to lay
out 12 of the vampire counsel in this
ancient temple with blades blood
combining with them this one night
because through comic book mumbo-jumbo
it'll make him a vampire God sue me but
whatever it sounds kind of fun there's
possibilities with it the downside is
where it took me only a few seconds to
say all that it takes the movie ten
minutes to do it yeah they just kind of
sit around talk well talk talking laugh
laugh and talk all we want to see is the
action but it takes four friggin ever
with detours but I know what you're
thinking through all of this whatever
happened to Karen's doctor friend the
one who got bitten what you weren't
wondering that while we're gonna spend a
lot of time on it anyway because hey
there's nothing better we could be doing
and we know it's eating you up inside
with curiosity he's a zombie now yeah
you do the math on that one it's some
sort of bullshit side-effect that
sometimes happens after being bitten
sure and vampire Sparkle too but who
cares about that because who cares about
all of this it's literally just ten
minutes of slow boring filler
and it feels like an eternity you're
afraid we're gonna steal yourself your
pure blood spirit you should be read the
prophecy it's time you fucks contributed
something to the cause even if Frost is
right you really think he cares about
you you're gonna die
well I guess he wasn't neither for the
ceremony but they just bring him along
because he looks like William Fichtner
because to be fair every movie needs
more William Fichtner after the
ceremonial ripping open up the shirt
very necessary Caryn escapes and tells
blade to suck her blood to get his
strength back all of the temple is
turned into a human plasma ball
of course all vampire skeletons have
tiny skeletons inside of them just
trying to get out what swings how long
do we have to wait again
okay okay blade does Freud proud by
penetrating his mother with a long hard
bone
resulting in him finally jumping in to
get revenge I got two new hands blade I
don't know which one to use to kill you
with well doesn't matter what I do now I
am never topping that throughout the
rest of the fit from here it's all the
cool stuff you wanted to see amazingly
flippable guards ripping our guy's
throat just to throw it at another guy
being launched in the air via nut kick
even the stuff that's kind of stupid is
really awesome
like how Karen continues to hit
everything except what she's supposed to
hit this weird scene where they keep
taking the air for some reason Maximus
madness madness madness madness madness
madness mass Junction out on earth and
the fact that even though there's
weapons that can clearly kill vampires
everything's abusing them on blade what
do you got there but a plank of wood oh
yeah that'll take him down
ooh a shovel that has to be as a doing
play destroy by deadly shovel you guys
really thought you'd be gods you're
using what elicits me
aliens from signs is not gonna do much
fuck is because it's still kick as gory
amazingness all building up to the final
boss hey blade
but it looks like his blood is made from
pizza cheese as well as some other
cartoony extras hi finally the time has
come for me to stop doing those stupid
Ebates commercials but blade finds the
serum that makes vampires go boom and he
eludes them up front
resulting in him saying his big
finishing line so motherfuckers are
always trying to pace Kato bill that is
a really weird note to go out on to this
date I can't figure out if that was
really clever or one of the dumbest
lines ever said by a comic-book
character what do you think the other
variations were some of the truckers are
always trying to put diesel in their
SUVs some peanut M&Ms always trying to
melt in your hand but not in your mouth
some sushi patrons are always trying to
mix that soy sauce with wasabi some fast
food lovers are always ordering Little
Caesars without the crazy bread some
vacationers are always trying to go to
Disney World at peak times when it's
obvious that mid-november through
mid-december is the best time to go I
mean seriously just bring a sweater and
you'll be fine
and don't forget to take advantage of
those hotel villages with free shuttle
bus service full price for their
monorail access resort's I don't think
so Mouse he kicks the last needle into
his head finishing him off
huh so I guess he can't put himself
together after that being a god just
means being slightly less destructible
than you already work good to know that
the ancient gods of old can't compete
with head blowy up science so we all
know the drill blade and caring kiss and
a romantic embrace even though they have
very little income I need to get back to
the lab it's not over there's still a
war going on and I have a job to do uh I
don't think you know how this works he's
a dude you're a chick you have to end up
together even if you have no chemistry
at all it's like a law you want to help
make me a bed cereal
Wow really they don't get together there
is such a thing as a man and a woman
working together in an action film and
they don't have to hook up quickly tompa
who are you write this ending so that
not only do they get together but they
had 20 children all with different
sexual identities 20 sexual identities
don't exist make them up you're good at
that we travel to Moscow for a really no
reason except to get this cold shot and
we end with him hunting vampire ass once
more
that was blade an overlooked comic-book
staple and to be on is still pretty damn
cool okay the writing's not always good
and there's a lot of nineties cheese but
there's just a style and a creativity to
it that still makes it really enjoyable
it's not too mopey that it can't be fun
but it's not too silly that it can't be
serious it's visually awesome its
characters are entertaining and the
action is still impressive and gets you
sucked in it got people saying comic
book movies could be cool at a time when
they were being seen as box-office pearl
harbors this is one of the films that
helped get movies like Dark Knight and
Iron Man into the spotlight again so
they want something that rarely makes
sense but still a pretty rockin good
time this is definitely one to take a
look at
I'm the Nostalgia Critic and some food
by the foots are always a few inches
short coming next week we see if Batman
mask of the phantasm is the best Batman
movie ever but you can see it now under
vessels ad free early access just three
dollars a month to see tons of people's
videos early as well as a bunch of other
extra features check it out and get the
early scooter
you
some motherfuckers are always trying to
ice-skate Oh bill hey Doug Walker here
doing the charity shout out and this
week we are doing nd8
org everyday muscle debilitating
diseases take the abilities we take for
granted away from kids and adults we
love but every day MDA families are
doing remarkable things to live beyond
their physical limits NDA's live
unlimited movement is inspired by the
courage and strength of those families
to celebrate what we can do and be
relentless in their pursuit of making
more can-do moments possible from
Advisory Committee meetings to research
grains to even passing a bill to
increase National Institutes of Health
funding it's impossible to count all the
incredible things that they accomplished
you may know them best for the Jerry
Lewis telethon or their MDA shamrocks
which you can see at any store but you
can go beyond just donating with those
two and check out their site to see all
the great work that they do
listen to their stories watch their
videos and see how you can help people
live the everyday life that they deserve